hi my name is Allison Kimball I work at
Wolfram research and I'm going to be
talking about our mentorship program hi
my name is Emma yang I'm an eighth
grader in new york and i'll be talking
about my learning experience with the
Wolfram mentorships program
today I'm going to talk a little bit
about our mentorship program and
introduce Emma who's actually one of the
students in the mentorship program so
you might have heard a little bit about
the program from Stevens keynote but
just some background info it's part of
the Wolfram Foundation which is part of
our educational and it's initiative side
of things so things like the summer
programs or local outreach or even the
new computational thinking initiative
are part of the wolfyn foundation so it
started just about hmm maybe 18 months
ago and it really picked up speed last
August which is when I started working
here so so the basic idea is that it's a
virtual mentorship so we will work on a
project with a student for three to six
months working like five to ten hours a
week on their side and then meeting with
them for about a half hour to an hour a
week so who's in the program right now
we have about 20 students and they are a
wide variety of Ages but for the most
part they're in high school so Emma as
you can tell us a little bit on the
younger side of things but we also have
people who are transitioning careers or
in college or some summer school
students who decided to continue with
their projects after the summer school
but for the most part they are high
school students one thing that the
students all have in common is that they
are already comfortable with the Wolfram
language or at least can get comfortable
pretty quickly so it's not so much a
boot camp like our summer programs it's
more so can you build this project so I
guess the next thing to talk about is
what type of projects are done in the
mentorship program so we have a list of
open projects that for the most part
that's what the students are choosing
from and there's a huge range of project
so things that don't involve any
programming at all like adding to our
word list and finding obscure languages
and adding words in or even tracing the
history of math textbooks or things like
generating art using neural networks but
then there are really programming having
projects like connecting to d-wave API
or loris appear connected ro s to the
Wolfram language and was able to that
drone is being powered by his code
another project is fingerprint
identification and then there are things
that are sort of in between like medium
programming so building classifiers or
can't really tell it's a bad image but
that codes part of a cryptography pod
project so with that I'm going to
introduce Emma and let her take things
but i'll be around after to answer
questions if you have any about the
mentorship program ok so I'm in eighth
grader in New York and I've been in the
mentorship program since Scott January
so let me tell you how it all got
started so last year I went to a maker
faire at in New York which is like all
this like these tech foots going present
their work and dr. Wolfram was making a
talk there and I my tenant has talked
and then I was I actually discussed with
him a project i was doing involving
image identification and he pointed me
in the direction of the mentorship
program like a few months later and then
he actually also sent me his then pretty
new book an elementary introduction to
the Wolfram language and actually one
morning I was called into the
principal's office and I thought that I
had done something wrong but then it
turned out that dr. Wolfram and actually
mailed me a book and then they want to
give it to me so that was pretty cool so
I joined the mentorship program this
January and I started by learning how to
do the Wolfen language because prior to
that I didn't really
have much experience in it so I began by
following with the book mainly the
online version I worked through the
exercises which are part of each chapter
of the book which I thought were really
helpful and I met up weekly with my
mentors and we discussed all these
challenging areas that I was having
trouble with and then after I a period
of time when I got pretty comfortable
with the language I identified a project
with them so I could apply what I've
learned so what I really like about the
Wolfram language in terms of learning
experience is how easy and
instantaneously you can do
visualizations so in other language I've
learned like scratch java Swift there
was a lot of setup you have to do before
you can actually generate stuffs and
there's a lot of things that you get to
initially learn and learn how to do
before you can actually get your hands
into coding what I really like about
Mathematica and the Wolfram language is
that you can easily just generate a line
of code that will generate things like
circle states or 3d images of like of
these of structures of for example here
I have a skull I also really like how
does a lot of built-in data so in other
languages you have to kind of import
data or take data from somewhere else
and it takes a lot of time to learn how
to import that data and then process it
and then make it usable hear what I
really like is that mathematica
everything is built into the language so
you can connect to Wolfram Alpha and get
pictures of planets for example and then
I can play around with that and there's
also I can there's also a really wide
range of data I can get so we also have
things like speeches and then we have
texts from books and things like that so
there are really a lot of applications
of the language that exists that you
don't need to have a lot of experience
with the language until to get there you
can just start playing around with it so
what's different about learning the
Wolfram language with my experience so
far is that I really like how these
concepts really build on each other's so
and also everything connects to create a
bigger picture so in other languages you
really have to have a lot of foundation
before you can do kind of multi-level
programming here you can really get your
hands into it and things really build on
each other and it's a lot easier to get
your hands in
to it and also it doesn't really focus
on one single programming paradigm so in
Java for example you have to learn how
to do object orientation and then learn
all that set up things that you can't
really you don't really need to do with
the Wolfram language so here we can just
start get your hands into the coating
and get started and all that gives more
you more room to experiment around with
the language and to can just play around
and learn through experimenting which i
think is much more interesting to me
rather than having to go through like
this is this concept that's this concept
before you can actually start playing
around and having fun with the language
so a couple things that I found
challenging what were things like things
that didn't really pop up in other
language conventional languages so for
example patterns don't really turn out
where you can have filter out different
criteria from like a set of data so that
I didn't really find in other any other
languages so in general new concepts
also kind of things that work repeating
functions and pure functions when I
found really helpful to go overcome
those challenges though where things
like for example we're here this is I
found pretty straightforward but once we
got things like this it could get
confusing from jumping from a pretty
simple example to like a more complex
thing so what I found was really helpful
was to see step by step like how do you
get from stay here to program something
a little more complicated like this so
for another example that would be here
this is I found pretty simple like you
can blur each circle and in the list but
then once we got to this it can get more
confusing so I thought that if my
mentors really gave me good step-by-step
explanations which really helped in the
process so so far with the mentorship
program I've done two projects so the
first one was on data well most of them
have been encompass saying how like data
visualization using the Wolfram language
so the first one I did was starting in
about january-february time and I did
one where i found this data set from the
New York City open data which has all
this government data from the
city which is where I'm from and there
was one dataset on all these motor
vehicle collisions around the city so i
used i took that data and put into
mathematica and i was able to analyze
and build tools where you can build
visualizations like grass maps and
things like that of like the different
causes of accidents distribution over
time of day and things like that the
second one is I'm participated in quite
recently this one was called the
opportunity project which was a project
run by the white house in which we took
all this government open data that
existed and built tools that could help
the government find all these
opportunities for people all around the
country so i took this data set that
they have on their the usda's Summer
Food Service Program which is all these
summer meal sites they have to find
summer meal sites for kids over the
summer who usually get lunch from school
but then they don't have an alternative
over the summer so I built a tool where
you can kind of zoom in on zip codes for
DC to find the summer meal sites so when
me the next steps i'm really going to
i'm trying to dive into like neural
network the machine loading within the
mathematica and also i'm really
interested in the Internet of Things the
intersection between that and the
Wolfram language so that's like the next
steps for me so I just want to talk
about the structure of the mentorship
program and my experience through it so
I meet with Allison and I Elementary's
weekly and then we go over like my
project I'm doing any trouble are having
with coding and they're like approaches
for me I want to build something then
how should I approach this problem and a
lot of things like that so I think that
from my learning experience the book the
elementary introduction to the Wolfram
language book is a really great place to
start it has a lot of really great
example step-by-step kind of examples on
each concept and also the development
platform is like a free online platform
one can sign in for free and they can
just start playing around with code and
it's connect to the programming lab
which is I think is really helpful
because I I try it out using that and it
has all these exploration
on how you can do like for example the
circle escapes I showed before was from
there where you can just it'll show you
how to do a lot of cool things using
code and it's basically made a made so
that kids can learn how to explore
around with code and play around it
within themselves yeah so I would just
like to give a special thanks to dr.
Wolfram for introducing me to the
monstrous program and then my mentors
from Wolfram Allison John and Todd yeah
so thank you
[Applause]